this is a game from believe it or not
2005
my first international tournament the
world youth championship under 10.
wow i was nine years old
and i think i told you this story but
this tournament was
so poorly organized and the world youth
chess championships are generally known
to be
like the the highest bidder is usually
the most corrupt organizer so the
organization usually isn't great
but this organizer actually went to jail
after this tournament
concluded because the temperature in the
playing hall was over 100 degrees
and the air conditioning did not work
and actually one of the kids
fainted during the tournament had to be
wheeled out on a stretcher
holy [ __ ] so he faced criminal charges
after the tournament concluded so
in that literal boiling pot i was
playing my games
i mean that was my first tasting of
international chess like is this what
chess looks like on the international
scene
the answer is no that's uncharacteristic
but just to give you some context
i think it should though i think it
should that's where men are born that is
where
you went in there nine years old and you
came out a [ __ ] man
exactly yeah i mean things got some
things got small and some things got big
in that playing hall and
you know amen things were things were
really decided there so
this position occurred in one of my
games um and it is
obviously it's white to move he's just
captured a knight that i put on c5 with
his knight from a6
the question is obviously well how do we
recapture this knight
and obviously supply an explanation for
your decision
you have two viable options taking with
a rook would be a terrible idea just
blundering the rook
so
so taking with the d-pawn now has your
e-pawn
not protected by a pawn anymore only
protected by the knight
and the bishop for taking well yeah in
the bishop but it's not protected by any
pawns
uh taking with the b pawn does the same
to the a
pawn um so let me ask you this sorry to
interrupt your
your genius the einsteinian thinking
process but it's okay yeah you can
stop it could the pawn on e5 before you
complete your theory of general
relativity could the pawn on e5
potentially be defended by a pawn
the f pawn yes yeah so that's another
important thing that you sometimes do
when you play d takes c5 this pawn is
not weak number one it's not attacked by
anything
number two it's protected by pieces so a
weak pawn isn't automatically a pawn
that's not defended by any pawns it's a
pawn that cannot even hypothetically
be protected by any other pawns you see
the difference there
this is the point can later on be
defended by f4 so it's not a big problem
that we've left it
quote unquote weak so that shouldn't be
a defining consideration but okay
continue thinking
yeah so i mean with that in mind now you
take with the d pawn
you take it on and what square do you
vacate for one of your pieces
now i now have the d4 for my knight
exactly what i wanted to hear he's got
to move his queen away
now do you play knight t4 immediately or
is there a preliminary move you make
uh do we need to prep it do we need to
start looking into like how to make this
more devastating it's a simpler question
like look at this position very closely
can we put the knight on d4 right now
or do we need to do something first
um oh we need to take the
uh yeah we have to take the bishop first
he's he's attacking our bishop with two
pieces
he's x-raying it so don't forget about
when you're playing positionally don't
forget about tactics don't forget to
check for hanging pieces all of that
still remains
it's just that yeah you just need to
remember that
attacking the queen and guess what i did
after he brings this queen back to d7
see your pants yeah well after of course
that goes to that
oh this is amazing you said that amazing
you said that
this is we're actually on the same
wavelength okay this is my tmi
but i want people to understand this the
atmosphere here this is great
during the second round now mind you
okay i'm nine years old this is france
first international trip i'm nervous
right nobody speaks english this is not
paris
like i told you all these tournaments
are in shitholes this is a town called
belfort
and i need to go to the bathroom um
and it's the second round and i don't
have a lot of time on my clock okay so i
make a move
i get up i start looking for the
bathroom normally there's a sign in
these playing halls you know the
international sign of needing to [ __ ]
urinate okay how hard could it be
you can't find it usually it's exit the
playing hall i asked the tournament
organizer like the little
men at the desk i tried bathroom
toilette whatever
like [ __ ] lippy lippy coming out
defense
no nothing they're like looking at me as
if i'm from [ __ ] mars
um i tried it in the most understandable
international language possible
nothing and finally as i'm about to pee
my pants i discovered that there are
porta potties
outside that the players are supposed to
use
which is i mean and you can understand
what state those porta-potties were in
but i narrowly narrowly averted
disaster in the second round and i
remember that to this day
oh that's good you didn't blunder uh
pissed pants that day good [ __ ]
i did not although there was there was a
little residue
left i don't know where the those pants
had a proper funeral let me just put it
that way
uh i'd hope you'd outgrow them within 15
years something else
you'd be surprised just take a look at
my wardrobe so in this position
you brought to my attention a problem
with this pawn on e5 guess what i did
now another prophylactic move just
making sure that no monkey business is
gonna happen
i'm imagining you protected that pawn
with f4 that's exactly what i did
another maintenance move nothing wrong
with doing something
in for the future self you know in case
he ever attacks that pawn again
and in fact the rest of this game the
game lasted another 23 moves but it was
very one-sided
and i just want you to find one more
idea so he moved his knight back to g8
um sorry no he did not do that yeah he
did do that he moves his knife back to
g8
and here i just played the move g3 just
you know protecting another pawn just
chilling
look at my position i'm completely
dominating him if he ever tries to break
apart
my pawn chain with b6 how are you going
to respond
to this move yeah you're just pushing
that pawn up to
c6 another benefit of putting that
knight on d4 bingo and then potentially
supporting it with b5
so he can't even do that what i want you
to do
is find a plan of action here we've put
all our pieces on beautiful squares
now we need to start attacking but how
do we attack here what move do we make
and this is going to be challenging but
i really want you to kind of learn these
attacking skills you need to break open
the position a little bit are there any
pawn breakthroughs that come to mind
uh nothing immediate the one thing that
i keep looking at
is pushing b4 to b5 and then playing c6
just to have another pawn to defend that
as a breakthrough but reasonable
reasonable plan but i was thinking more
on the king side there is a pawn
breakthrough that
that you can effect like immediately
here
is it pushing up well it can't be
pushing up it is pushing up the f6 pawn
isn't it
f4 pawn to f5 it is
it's tip for ty you know you weaken the
e pawn yes
but you have total positional domination
so the time has come to transform that
advantage
into something specific something
concrete so does this move make sense
mm-hmm
yeah he takes you take with the knight
you don't want to
put the rook there right right you take
with the knight and then i'll have that
x-ray on the g7 pawn then you start
looking for tactics
he plays bishop c7 attacking my pawn
well i defend it with queenie two
again nothing i'm not curing kovid with
this move i'm just defending the pawn
after queen e7 the last move that um
i'll sort of ask you to find because the
game drags on
it's it's just a move that has to occur
to you intuitively it's a further
breakthrough
that exposes essentially all of the
weaknesses in his position
um well what i looked at is since now
the bishop is blocking that rook
it was pushing the c5 pawn to c6 if he
takes you take your attacking queen
again
you mean like here here here
yeah but your what i would argue is
there's two problems with this move
number one you're derailing the knight
from its beautiful central square
and now it's hunting for gold and if
it's if you take a7 first of all you've
done all of this for a measly pawn
and second of all you've actually lost
the knight how can black win the night
now
did you just move the bishop right yeah
there's no squares well there should be
six check otherwise he would have taken
the rook
but this is a check oh you have to
deliver the check and then you take the
rook and then you take the knight
um so that's reason number one reason
number two is that when you're attacking
on the king side the best thing that can
happen to you is for the queen side to
be closed
if the queen said is closed that means
you don't have to worry about anything
that happens there
so by playing c6 you think that you're
doing yourself a favor
but you're actually doing your opponent
a favor by opening up that side of the
board
giving him a little bit of breathing
room for his pieces
okay that makes sense okay so it's a
breakthrough on the king's side
and it's technically upon sacrifice
although if he accepts that pawn
sacrifice he loses immediately
you rip apart the defenses on his king
side
anything coming to mind okay is it you
take this pawn first so you take
uh e6 here with f5
uh he can't take with queen because it's
protected by knight he has to take with
pawn
if he takes it all and then you take
rook he takes
with his rook mm-hmm and then
well all that you've done there is
created more pieces and opened the
position up and weakened this pawn
i can tell you the move that doesn't
work damn
it's it's a breakthrough you push upon
even further forward shattering his
kingside defenses
is it just pushing the pawn instead of
taking it to uh
and maybe the hesitancy is that if he
takes it with his knight and this is
again where you have to reappraise
what's when what's happened what have
you now gained as a consequence of
giving that pun up
which is a huge look at this i mean the
bishop is x-raying the knight
so now you have a crushing move you have
several crushing moves i want you to
find one of them
uh well the first one i'm looking at is
bringing knight to
f5
he wouldn't be able to take with pawn
because then i just win a queen
that's a great move the the move that i
think wins the
fastest is in the same spirit if you
move the knight away you threaten to
take on f6 with check and win the queen
right
yeah so by playing knight five you
obstruct the rook's control over the
night he can go quindy and he's still
kicking even though he's completely lost
could you move the knight somewhere
attacking the queen a
and b not obstructing the bishop and the
rook's control over
f6 there is a move that
fulfills checks both boxes
a move with this knight that attacks the
queen
and simultaneously thereby preparing
bishop takes f6 check
winning the game
i mean the only the only tile i see that
does that
is c6 but it just gets taken by pawn so
i don't think that's the right
now you but now you take the knight with
the bishop and you fork the king and the
queen
oh i see so oh jesus yep i see
i mean it's been a lot of different
tactics so i i don't
hold that against you but you see the
the idea now
i see yeah since the bishop's protected
by the rook when you deliver that
check the queen can't take it to relieve
that pressure has to move king
exactly and that's it i mean he's got to
move his queen
you take the knight and finally you have
checkmate in one
what move am i talking about yeah you
just bring the queen over to g4
yeah you're seeing these mates fast
which is good
your your like basic tactics have gotten
to a very good
point where like you don't need to
necessarily work on them specifically
but i think that's that's a good sort of
maintenance workout for now i mean we
could
we could do 40 of these positions and
we'll continue to do them
but i want to give you kind of a general
sense of the kinds of ideas that
exist in real chess so that you have a
greater menu to choose from because
again
you get to a situation where you don't
know what to do and you have a very
limited number of options at your
disposal do i attack the king well
there's nothing to do in that front
so what the [ __ ] do i do you know and
then you start hesitating and come up
with something shitty
so hopefully hopefully that gives you a
little little bit of a better sense
of what to do yeah that makes sense okay
so
um let's do a little bit of openings as
perhaps our final activity for the day
if that sounds good
sounds good to me if you're not
overwhelmed by all of this
i know this is all new no i think this
is all very good stuff i always need to
get this kind of exercise in
yeah and and it'll you know it might
take some time to to come together with
it but it will you do enough of these
positions and
you know eventually you just uh you just
start to find these plans automatically
that's what signifies improvement it's
when you don't have to
consciously ask yourself these questions
they enter your subconscious essentially
um okay so you see the starting position
yeah i'm going to start off showing you
the scotch
for night scotch and i'll give you the
lay of the land the crash course will
you be ready to immediately start
playing it
perhaps because part of the appeal
behind this opening is how intuitive it
is it's really just
it involves the development of all of
your pieces to very active squares
and it poses immediate challenges to
your opponent and there's a lot of lines
where black just loses very quickly
people are not going to know it
as well as they know the italian so
you're gonna win a lot of games with it
if you learn it properly
okay this sounds good to me it starts on
a familiar
note e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
and now there's two ways to to reach it
the the move order that i personally
like
um that i think is is a little bit more
pure
is the move knight to c3 okay
and black 99.9
of the time we'll play the move knight
f6 there are some people who play bishop
c5 here this is already kind of a
mistake and here you have a really cool
little
tactic that i'm sure you have run across
this before i'm going to show you what
it is you take on e5 with the knight
and you don't blunder the knight how do
you recover it
uh i i was going to say you deliver a
check and win it but
there's no checks to deliver i think i
know
what kind of tactics you need to keep
solving the forks are a little bit
you know they need to be crisper i don't
is it just the pawn fork
it is d4 okay you got to win the when
the pick but what you get in return is
that you get
huge piece development black has been
[ __ ] around with his pieces so
black needs to regain that pawn right he
if you take one of his pieces you're
going to be a pawn up
so normally black does something like
bishop takes d4
you play queen takes d4 you're skewering
the knight to the pawn
and if black defends the knight with d6
white is essentially winning now
with well you can dislodge this knight
from e5 how can you do that and then win
that pawn on g7
i just play a pawn move so i'm bringing
pawn uh f4
right bingo he goes he's got to move his
knight and then you take on g7 you're in
great shape you might even win that rook
at the end
so just remember this idea of taking on
e5 with the knight when his bishop is on
c5
if he responds with queen f6 um
all uh moist critical versus xqc
um yeah what comes to mind in terms well
he's hitting the pawn on f2 and hitting
the knight on e
on e5 can you defend both at the same
time and solidify your extra pawn
it's simpler than you think it is like
it's one of these retreating moves that
you might have a little bit of trouble
with because it's a retreat yeah
it's because it's just bringing the
knight back to f3 right
right exactly bringing the knight back
to f3 then you keep developing you can
hit that queen with knight d5
that's a move that recurs pretty often
in the scotch so bishop c5 is basically
[ __ ] nobody's really gonna do that
and now you play the move d4
um again the vast majority of people
are going to capture on d4 with the pawn
um
there's really no other
good or even common moves in this
position
the only move that you have to kind of
know is bishop to b4
and this is a little bit theoretical uh
which i don't
love but you're gonna encounter this so
infrequently that if you even know one
move in this position
you're gonna throw people off which is
knight takes e5
okay should be logical to you just
taking the pawn now black can reclaim
the pawn with what move
using the pin that he has just created
what move can black now play
yeah he just takes e4 he takes e4 now
you bring your queen out to f3
defending the knight hitting his knight
threatening checkmate
black's move is essentially force he has
to do the same thing that you would have
done in that other position right bring
his knight back to f6
now he's he's attacking d4 can you
develop one of your pieces in or and
simultaneously guard d4
yeah i'm bringing bishop to e3 bringing
bishop to e3 then you bring the bishop
to d3
and later on maybe next session we'll
look at a classical game
that shows you how to play in these
types of positions
with symmetrical pawns on d4 and d5 and
that's going to clarify a lot of the
common strategies for you
okay uh but for now um we'll keep our
eyes on the prize i want to kind of give
you the lay of the land so
here you take on e5 of the night if he
takes back first and then takes place
knight takes c4
do you remember our coverage of the pin
variation
so you said it was [ __ ] right it was
[ __ ] and
i mean i don't expect you to remember
the moves but
this position is reached in theory do
you remember the
the actual move that white plays here to
refute it
i'll give you a hint white hits that
knight on e4 and he hits the pawn on g7
simultaneously
oh yeah you just bring the queen out to
g4 there you go yep and then if i take c
do you remember the move knight takes c3
you don't take the knight obviously
because black takes and forks at rook
that would be a shitty idea
just the next movie i'm just taking
you're just taking the pawn
right bingo take the pawn on g7 then you
play a3
etc etc so here the idea is borrowed
it's
well not bar it's the same idea so take
stakes takes
queen g4 same exact concept
but slightly different whoa mr llamo 712
ray thank you so much mr lama appreciate
the
huge raid wow now the pressure's really
on charlie you better find the right
moves or you're going to make me look
bad which
ultimately there's no you got to be a
good teacher yeah well that pressure's
on you man
is it well we'll see about that so here
you actually have a choice you could
take the pawn on g7
simpler actually would be to snap off
this bishop
cutting well you're really cutting
black's nuts off because without this
bishop black is riddled with weaknesses
knight d5 and now
where where do you park your queen
i think there's a name for this um
where you like swing back and forth like
a grandfather clock
where should the queen now land wiper
like a windshield wiper the windshield
wiper perfect
well that's a shitty name don't you ever
use that again do you just bring it back
over to g4 to threaten that pawn again
excuse me copyright charlie trademark
2020.
the genius charlie bring it back to g4
and if black castles
another pin variation theme this is
something you should see quickly
white to play and pick off an exchange
or deliver checkmate
yeah so i'm just bringing the bishop out
there to c4
that attacks the night he moves the
knight away i don't know why you're so
attracted by there
this is a very common tactic
x-ray um yeah so i'm just bringing the
bishop out to h6
bingo he's got to play g6 now you take
the rook then you bring the bishop to c4
castle etc
i was a little too early but yeah so you
see it
good so this is all you need to know in
this line i mean bishop b4 is not common
so
e takes d4 is what you're going to see
most often and you play knight takes d4
now what is the general rationale behind
doing this well
by playing d4 you're opening up a really
nice development square for your bishop
you're bringing the knights out onto
onto good squares i mean what could be
terrible about that right it should be
pretty logical to you
yeah that makes sense so black has
essentially three moves that we're going
to look at the main move is bishop to b4
pinning your knight
this move looks scary but we'll talk
about how you respond to that
the second move is bishop to c5
and and we'll look at more than three
moves it's just that today i don't want
to bog you down too much so
the third move that we're going to look
at is a demonstration move
through the lens of which i'm going to
show you kind of the common ideas in
this line
now black can also take the knight on d4
which is not a great idea because then
your queen comes out into a very active
square we'll talk about that too
the move that we'll use for
demonstration purposes is just d6
now why is this move shitty from a
positional point of view what is it
block you can't develop your f bishop
tile bishop you gotta just develop it to
like e7 which is a pretty shitty square
now where would you develop your f1
bishop
uh we wouldn't we don't get a whole lot
out of pinning the knight i just play
the pawn so
yeah so we just want to put the bishop
back on c4 right well if we pin the
knight how does he defend the pin
oh you could just break it with a bishop
yeah he breaks it with the bishop right
well he can't play the pawn because then
you take twice so he breaks it with the
bishop he plays bishop c4 instead
bishop e7 newcastle he castles
and here you have several very much
viable ways of developing your pieces
but
this position allows you to make exactly
the kinds of maintenance moves that
perhaps you normally struggle with now i
would delay the development of the c1
bishop
because i want to see what black does
first does that kind of make sense i
don't want to decide
where i put the bishop maybe it'll be e3
maybe g5 but
let's see what black does first so
what's a normal good
solid maintenance move bringing one of
the pieces in you did it in your warm-up
game
that's also very flexible it's a movie
no it's gonna be good
yeah just e1 with the rook right exactly
now can you give me another one of those
moves which
prevents one of his pieces from
developing to its most active square
this is a prophylactic move i'm looking
for it covers a very important square
yeah so i want to
right now it's that pawn right we don't
want the knight on e4 so we protect or
no that's protected
that is already protected what we're
looking at is where could he put his ca
bishop
most actively and how do we take that
square away from him
yeah it's going to g4 with that bishop
ryden
so we just push that h pawn we do i like
the move h3 now
the last thing that we'll talk about for
now and then this bishop can come out to
g5
the rook to e1 you get a very harmonious
free
better position now a lot of people i'm
pretty sure
i'm calling it we'll take on d4 and
they'll follow up with c5 that's the
instinct that you had
in that warm-up game but this is
actually a horrible idea because
can you now tell me what weakness what
long-term weakness does this move create
which you can then attack that pawn on
d6 does not have a pawn to defend it
anymore so once you drop your queen to
d3
can you give me two moves that put
as much pressure as possible on that d6
pawn develop your pieces with an eye
toward attacking that pawn
we have bishop to f4 attacking the pawn
directly and we have
knight to oh no yeah we have knight two
p5 potentially although again you know
what i feel about how i feel about these
knight moves to the side
yeah in a situation like this knight b5
would be an advisable it would drop the
e4 pawn
so you want to keep your knights unless
you have a very good reason not to
you want to keep your knights
controlling important central square so
i'm looking for a different move here a
more harmonious move
okay um
keep pressuring that pawn on d6 it's a
very natural move
is it just pushing the pawn up there to
e5 well then you don't attack the pawn
you you allow black to get rid of it
yeah no he just gets the ai yeah you're
literally looking for a way to attack
the spawn further
don't forget about your rooks you're
only i feel like you're only looking at
your
minor pieces your knights are bishops
but your rooks can participate in the
attack
so we just need it on d1 then rocated e1
this other row could come out to e1
look at how beautiful white's position
is every piece is playing
now what would be a plan in this
position well there's a million things
you could do
you could move the queen out of the way
setting up an x-ray and then you could
play e5 when the time is right
such that black cannot take the pawn and
then you take d6 that would be one plane
does that make sense
makes sense another plan would be a well
i think i mentioned the rook lift
and a third plan would be potentially
bringing a knight to d5 just a very nice
central square
and keep pushing him off the board bit
by bit improving the position
step by step until eventually something
cracks either he allows an attack
against his king
or i don't know one of many things might
happen okay
and you need to be okay with that you
don't know exactly how you're gonna win
this game but
something is gonna give here
before uh before we get too deep into
the openings there's one thing i wanted
to ask you yeah
this is something i picked up during
three minute games just because i
struggled so much with time
can you reset the board and i show you
something and you just play against it
like in the most natural way that you
would
absolutely um okay i'll go back to the
start
okay so that i i did this a lot of times
and
almost zero i'd say like 50
of the time i would just immediately win
the game
assuming assuming knight gets played so
you play
f6 okay so i'm just manually relaying
because they're not all the moves are oh
yeah this the fried lever attack
yeah and then it's take here and then
take seven yep that is the famous line
so black has to play knight a5 here if
he knows what he's doing
okay but this is i'm how did you find
out about this
uh i played against it and i i fended it
off
but i thought it was extremely strong it
is it's winning for white this is a
forced win for white
yeah knight c3 here attacks the knight
on d5 it's a famous night sacrifice it's
been around since the 19th century
and it refutes it refutes the move
knight takes d5
so that is one of the appeals
of playing this at your level but i was
under the impression that the vast
majority of people go bishop c5
so um most people well when i played it
most people developed that night really
four is the most common really okay
so we can actually make a detour i could
show you
this specific line and then you'll have
two
potential lines at your disposal now
keep in mind this was at 900 so it might
be different at a thousand though well
but
less than four thousand this is like a
no-brainer like it'll take me five
minutes to show you the ropes in that
position
and then you'll have this as a weapon if
you don't feel like playing the scotch
if you feel
if you're feeling lucky um and if they
play bishop c5 here
of course there's theory in this line
too i could show you mainline theory but
it's
it's a little bit dry and a lot of
people know this so after knight f6
knight g5
uh d5 takes if they if they make the
correct move knight a5
you're supposed to give a check on b5
okay
and they're supposed to block with a
pawn now i think most people at your
level will not know this they will block
with the bishop
and here you make a very strong move try
to remember this move you play queen to
e2
and you simultaneously defend the bishop
and hit the pawn on e5 if they take
whoops sorry if they take the bishop you
take back
forking the king and the knight they can
unfork themselves with c6
but now you just take c6 and again
they're in trouble because
if they take with the knight then what
hangs
the pawn the pawn on b7 and if they hate
if they take with a pawn what hangs
the pawn well no no it's protected by
knight yeah well the
a-pawn but which pawn yeah the e5
bingo the e5 so yeah queen e2 was a very
important move
if they take on d5 um and one of my
earliest
games continues now it's very important
to give this check first you do not want
to go knight c3 first
because that allows the defensive bishop
e6 and black is winning
so first you give it a chance so i can
tell you how the computer tells you the
optimal play is here when you deliver
this check it tells you to play queen
right there to intercept but then i
always played this and that's when
they'd panic
sometimes they just immediately just
[ __ ] checkmate themself well yeah i
mean this white is remember white is up
upon now
and white is still attacking so in this
situation
this is one of those cases where you
could trade queens um
and get a much better end game and that
probably constitutes white's best option
but
if you want to refrain from the queen
trade you could also play something like
queen e3
and just keep the queens on the board
then you castle and quickly start
attacking that king which has lost its
castling rights remember
okay that makes sense so what i
typically do when they drop
king i take here delivers the check they
take
i take and then i'm sorry i don't take
sorry i went out of order but
nine times out of ten they're gonna drop
the queen at least in the games at 900
and then i win a rook
i just wanted to know how to play
against it in case i just freaked out oh
you're talking about it from blackside
so this is what you
face i played the i played this to win a
[ __ ] ton of games but i never really
thought like the right plays against it
i just tried
it off do you want to learn it so which
side are we looking at both sides i
guess you want to be able to play it
with white and you want to be able to
defend against it with black
it's not something i really care to play
it just seemed like a little speed run
strategy and
if i got the way i'd defend is i'd
immediately play this like the second i
saw bishop come out
but i didn't know if there was something
better i could do
oh okay okay okay so you want to know
how to play against it with black
well ideally yeah okay so what you want
to do well
i could show you let me think about this
i could show you a very cool trap line
that will win you a lot of games
but it's unsound but nobody's gonna know
the refutation
sounds fine it's called the trexler
variation
bishop c5 and
it looks like a horrible move it looks
like a blunder
because it looks like it blunders the
[ __ ] pawn enough sound with a fork
like what kind of idiot comes up with
this
and actually give me one second i'm
gonna pull up my
i have some analysis here i want to make
sure i don't [ __ ] this up for you
it's been mind you years since i've
actually looked at this line
so i'm pulling up my own analysis give
me a second
so knight takes f7 is what you're gonna
face and now you make an amazing move
this is you're going to have fun here
bishop takes f to check
what the [ __ ] are you doing like your
sacrifice hanging everything
so obviously well they take your bishop
right we'll talk about some of the
sidelines here
but i want to spend some time on this
because it's it really is worth
so let's say they take the bishop right
i'm assuming that's what
what most people are going to do and
then you play well what do you think
that you do after they take the bishop
this next move is actually very natural
yeah you just have to move the queen
right it's got to go to e7 well no
think about the spirit of the track sir
you've already sacked a bishop
and now you're just gonna humbly move
your queen away and give up a [ __ ]
rook that's that's not the
this is a big decline i thought you were
into that kind of [ __ ]
but apparently apparently you're playing
queen e7 here rather than
continuing the attack is it
bringing f1 or f8 with the rook so when
it takes with the
that's a good thought it's actually just
a it's a check that you're missing
because you're you're tunnel visioning
this attack so you're not looking at his
king
and what could happen to his king so
you're just delivering another check
with the knight at g4 not a g4 that
blunders the knight to the queen
but you're taking a pawn with check
oh e4 yeah that's just a bit of a blind
spot knight e4
okay sorry this is a little bit
theoretical so if you feel like it's too
much maintenance for this one line
tell me but it is gonna become very
popular so
i think it's gonna be worthwhile to know
this and it's gonna win you a lot of
games just on the spot
they go back to g1 95 of the time
in fact that's the only good move if
they bring the king forward
to e3
and one moment my computer is not
handling all of that traffic give me a
second
my computer is freezing up can you still
hear me
yep okay just one moment there we go so
if he brings the king up to e3
uh then we play queen to h4
and if they take the rook we have
checkmate in just a couple of moves
do you see how this starts
the first move being oh no that hangs
tonight yeah you would i like that you i
like that you didn't make that move
relinquishing control over that now you
want to give a check but simultaneously
keep the knight on e4 under control
right
so you deliver the next check at f4
protected by pawn
bingo if they go king d3 it's checkmate
in two moves
find it
you deliver a check at b4 with the
knight he can't go to c3 it's protected
by r
knight which gives him one escape square
which is
d4 you'd bring knight back to
d2 f6 this this square is covered
so he's gotta go back to e2 you're
absolutely right though and you have
checkmate and one here
yeah and now now you're bringing the
queen to f2 right bingo
so checkmate okay so so this move i mean
they will not know what to do after
queen h4 and we'll flesh this out
further we'll practice this but
giving you the lay of the land right now
okay
that seems cool but the way like i said
the way i
if when i see it with the bishop come
out i just immediately play h
uh i don't remember h6 to cut it off in
which position here
yeah so the second they play that bishop
i just play this
you if you want to just cut everything
out you can just develop your bishop to
c5
first so that the g5 score remains under
your control
okay so just instead of even playing the
pawn yeah you don't need to play h6
that's
that's a actually it's a bad move
because it gives them more time to
develop and then you develop your
knights f6 on the next move
so that if they play knight g5 you can
just castle and defend the pawn
so just remember don't play knight f6
there play bishop c5 we can continue
that
trackster line later um it's a good line
to know in general once you get
you know once you get to i guess 12 1300
we can pick this up but i just wanted
you to know
what's out there okay um that makes
sense
for now just play bishop c5 first and
then you don't even need to play h6
that's the key
okay is that what did you call it again
that
that whole line in the beginning where
it's attacking that f7 pawn right away
what is that
so knight g5 is called the fried liver
attack i don't have
no [ __ ] clue why i hate fried liver
um just foie gras that's the concept
makes me wretch
sorry i hope maybe you're a fan i've
never had it it sounds terrible
wait i need to close my [ __ ] window
one sec there's a
scary [ __ ] bug okay get the [ __ ] out
let me just make sure my balcony door is
closed it's open
lock it all right
grandmaster attacked by north carolinian
hornet okay we're good i'm glad you
survived
yes that was i hate bugs just so you
know
i you did more than i would i would have
just called my girlfriend to take care
of it i can't be around bugs
i can't either i scream and run out of
the room when i encounter
the tiniest there was a lizard living in
my house it's not even a bug there was a
[ __ ] lizard living in my house for
the last couple months
he i was going to bed fearful one night
it was above my door going into the
bedroom and i was like holy [ __ ] i'm not
sleeping tonight it's like a curse
and the next night it was on my [ __ ]
tv and i could i couldn't touch it so i
just left it there the whole night
oh my god what are you sat there yeah no
he was putting me in check right there i
just i didn't want to take it i couldn't
do anything about it i was afraid of him
i hate i hate
little creepy crawlies where they're not
supposed to be
disgusting [ __ ] just gonna like
bite you yeah disgusting yeah
i don't i can't yeah it's just one of my
biggest fears um
anyways but this line is called the
fried lover attack
and the response bishop c5 is called the
traxler variation i assume after a guy
named traxler
he's not a famous chess player not all
variations are named after a famous
chess player
he was just someone who happened to
develop this first i suppose
someone i was asking was it a charlotte
hornet very funny
um yeah so that's just the
i guess the etymology of it but anyways
um
we can finish off that line the
demonstration line in the scotch
and that'll give you kind of a sound
basis unless you have more questions
about this line
no that's i think you answered it pretty
well okay so
back to the scotch knight c3 d4
so we were looking at sort of the
demonstration line d6 where you develop
your bishop to c4
castle rookie one etc so i think you get
the point here
let's just take a brief look at the main
line um sorry it's here in the bishop b4
and that'll kind of set you up with this
initial basics of the line so here
you take the knight on c6 okay
discharging the central tension
it doesn't matter what pawn he takes
with they're always going to take with
the beep on because taking with a d-pawn
allows you to take the queen with check
and you know deprive them of castling
right so you don't have to take their
queen with check but
most people are not going to take with a
d-pawn for that reason
now do you see what black is threatening
here
um we still have the pawn hanging that
knight still can't move
um could place that rook on v8 since
it's now an open file
yeah but there's a more immediate threat
that exploits the pen
i mean it's a move that i named
previously it just happened to not work
you know in a previous line but it still
is a threat
like there's just i don't i guess i
don't see what's exploiting the pin
beside
oh yeah yeah oh jesus okay yeah because
you can't take with the knight i get it
yup don't forget about those moves when
the knight is pinned it doesn't have
control over any squares so you play the
move bishop to d3
the idea being reinforcing the pawn so
that if knight takes you take with a
bishop
and then the follow-up is very simple
you castle
and you want to put the c1 bishop on g5
and you just want to checkmate the
knight by playing e5
and what you like about this line is
that you can very quickly play the moves
f4 and e5 i know you like to bring that
f pawn out
you get to do that here so for example
if they castle
you can castle first just tucking your
king away and if they make a move such
as d6
you play bishop g5 and you have a very
simple plan f4 and e5
and winning that night and crashing
through delivering checkmate it's a very
intuitive line once you get the
basics of it down
okay i've went fast through this line
but essentially that's
that is the rationale that are those are
the basics of the
four knight scotch um this bishop on d3
might look dull but it's actually
trained at that h7 punk
you see when white plays e5 it opens up
the bishop's
contact to h7 mm-hmm
um so is that making sense
yeah can you just uh play like the
progression from there though just so i
see it
yeah exactly exactly totally yeah so
exactly it was the wrong response to
that query
um the complete non-sequitur
so let's say bishop e6 happens um
well given what i told you what do you
think you do
you're still just pushing that f pawn
right there yeah it hasn't changed
anything
right so let's say that they play h6
trying to
break the pin where do you go
we're just dropping the bishop back to
h4 right right and there's one thing you
have to know
let's say that your rookie a you don't
want to go e5 immediately
because after it takes takes it might
look like you win the night
but they have a counter blow that wins
this pawn on e5 can you spot it
it's a it's a little fork it forced the
king in the pawn i guess
it forks the king in the pawn so you're
bringing the queen to d4
yep that's exactly what black does i'm
pinning himself attacking the bishop the
king in the pawn and then you basically
want to take the pawn afterwards
so this is a perfect example of
prophylaxis
the problem is queen d4 isn't such a
scary move in and of itself it's the
problem the problem is
is that it's a check so can we take the
sting out of that move with a
prophylactic move here
yeah we just tucked the king at h1 bingo
and now we're threatening e5
and e5 is a huge threat that cannot be
easily stopped because
if black gets his queen out of the pin
then what does this allow
we win the night well we don't win the
night but we take the night and we
ruin black's pawn structure essentially
right
and now how do we progress the attack
um we want to push up that
f pawn yep that's a great start we we
lock up black's pieces
and now we have the king all to
ourselves and how do we finish him off
we're throwing the queen over to g4
there's
even a better square than g4 what
attracts you about this move is that
it's a check but it's counterproductive
because now he gets to bring his rook
into g8 uh okay
yeah so we're swinging it all the way
over to h5 then bingo and now
finally you have a very conventional
idea you'll find it immediately
how do we actually bring this attack to
the next level
by doing a rook lift right that's
exactly what we do by doing a rook lift
to f3 to g3
black is not able to retain all of his
pawns and
you know there's some work required to
check mate black but
a lot of your games are going to take
one of these types of
avenues you know where you one way or
another you either get e5
in or you take the knight ruin the pawn
structure and checkmate them
okay so going down the line i'm looking
for the f
and the e pawn i'm looking to play those
two moves up there at f4
and e5 right right you're not
dogmatically like putting your head down
and doing it at all costly the funny
thing is
even when e5 is a sacrifice it's still a
good idea so let's say
i'm just gonna play a couple of sample
moves here um
let's say you play e5 and you're like oh
[ __ ] you know okay i blundered the pawn
well you didn't actually blunder the pun
you've sacrificed it because now the
rook has
contact in the night and what kind of
move can we play now
it's nothing it's not a sacrifice it's
just a helpful move that ruins the pawn
structure in front of black's king we
just take that knight
we take that knight we force the pawn
capture now where can this knight on c3
go
in order to attack the pawn on f6 and
cause
e4 yeah knight e4 etc i mean
one good thing about the scotch is that
you are almost guaranteed these
positions where
you're trying to attack one way or
another you're going to learn a lot more
about the art of
properly attacking and positioning your
pieces and when to play fast when to
play slowly
all of those secondary skills that are
going to bring you to 13 1400
they're a lot easier to attain if that
makes sense by playing this opening
rather than by playing the italian with
z3 because you literally get the same
exact types of positions you don't
normally get a chance to attack quickly
here you're always going to get a chance
to pressure black's king
one way or another that's going to
propel you to
new heights essentially okay uh
yeah let's take it back from the top
then let's roll and there's one more
line we have to look at but first i want
to review this
so take white and i'm going to take
black okay
so if bishop b4 just in your head do you
remember the move
uh i'm taking the pawn right with my
knight with the knight yep
so i'm gonna take your pawn the other
move we have to look at is bishop c5 but
we'll talk about that um we'll talk
about that separately so let's say
bishop b4 for now
okay then the line continues uh i'm
going here
um i'm looking at your stream because
it's not now be very careful about
trying to remember
versus trying to look at the position
this splendor is a knight on d4 oh
right so preliminary move
is what i just take tonight you just
take the knight
i take the pawn and this is going to be
very important when you first start
playing this
if you all of a sudden have forgotten
hopelessly
do not i repeat do not try to kind of
remember and fill in the blanks just
think independently and try to find a
reasonable move that's always going to
turn out better than misremembering and
blundering something
okay and then after this it's a castle
e1
and there is there is one line where you
don't actually fulfill that plan which
is where black plays d5 here i don't
anticipate a lot of people knowing that
even reaching this far is at all where i
don't know what people are going to play
we're going to get we're going to see
that when you start playing this
okay i'd want to play e1 first before
doing these pawn moves right
uh no i would i would develop the bishop
first actually bishop bishop usually
comes out first
so that you can pin
okay so then i want to play the bishop
first here and then play the pawns
and then play you can do it in any order
you can play rookie you can play f4
i wouldn't even play rookie one that is
a movie you only play if necessary
so i would immediately start pushing
those pawns out
okay well that makes sense to me then
and then you can tuck your king rookie
one queen can also come out to f3 i
should point out
you're not in a hurry to play e5 like if
you don't get a chance to play e5 that
doesn't mean your opening strategy has
failed
your position is imposing enough as it
is you don't always have to play e5 you
can do something like a queen lift to g3
x-raying the g-pawn that's also possible
so
one of the keys in this opening is going
to be to remain flexible
and not tie yourself down to the same
ideas
and being able to be flexible and
inventing new stuff that makes sense
that makes sense okay so uh when would i
want to look for
queen on f3 that's just a great move to
make in general like
if e5 is not immediately appealing your
default
is is you want to prepare e5 and you do
that by playing f4
usually you tuck your king away and then
you play e5 if the situation permits now
there are some situations where for one
reason or another black has found a way
to stop you from playing e5
um and if you're not as attracted by
that possibility
or even if you want some variation queen
f3 is good
and then you bring your other rook to e1
and then e5 could potentially be even
stronger
so it's an alternate plan in this
position is to play queen f3
then put the rook on e1 and then play
the move e5
and pin the knight and all of your
pieces are then essentially
in the game if that makes sense okay
yeah that makes sense
um so you know we're going to do
a lot of dedicated work on this opening
based on the games that you play in it
but you know i don't want to overly
overbog you down with with
theory first time you look at this line
um
essentially you can do the same thing
against bishop c5 you can take
you go bishop d3 castles bishop g5
and tuck your king away f4 e5 so
that's sort of a shortcut to
being able to play even if they play
bishop c5 so your default is you take
the knight you go bishop d3 bishop g5
etc
is that kind of making sense makes sense
to me yeah
so that is i would say kind of a level
one crash course
in the scotch um for a night scotch
uh hopefully once you start playing it i
will get a sense of how people actually
respond to it at your level i don't know
what people are gonna do uh most
frequently so
that'll be a learning experience for me
and on the basis of that we're gonna
deepen
our analysis in the direction that most
people play
okay um make it more focused that's a
good idea yeah so
so that'll be i mean do you think you
you would potentially try this on your
own or
or do you feel like you would want one
more like analysis session in the scotch
before you know i think i could
definitely try it on my own a lot of it
like you said
seems like intuitive moves moves that i
would most
likely recognize i'd hope if i'm not
sucking fat ass and it's
well that's a good question but it's not
the sort of opening where
if you [ __ ] it up you still get a
fundamentally sound
position um with good development so
what i want to make clear is that you
don't need to adhere religiously to
these ideas these ideas are guidelines
for how to play
that doesn't mean in every single
position you play exactly like that you
want to make normal
i'm trying to give you a compass that
allows you to
play virtually any position that's the
ultimate goal
you can see any position from any
opening and be
able to play it decently that's what a
grandmaster can do um
you're not there yet but that's what
you're aiming for by the time
we're not far off exactly we're knocking
on the door basically
[Music]
you